have you ever wondered what scientific
research looks like in the cloud
researchers are using Google Cloud to
gain new insights into disease and
discovered drugs and therapies to
improve patients lives today I will dive
in to show how high performance
Computing using the HPC toolkit can help
let's see how
whether it's drug Discovery genomics or
computational chemistry and biology
Google Cloud's flexible and scalable
high performance Computing for life
science Solutions are ready to help you
innovate
scientists are using our HPC platform
today to run large-scale virtual library
screenings
simulate the behavior of Target proteins
and promising drug-like compounds and
run powerful tools like free energy
perturbation calculations on fleets of
the latest gpus
there are many advantages to running
your workloads on Google cloud
configurable and repeatable HPC
deployment options help you efficiently
run and manage scientific workloads
flexible pricing means you only pay for
what you need meaning the cost savings
for your organization
and scalable architecture means reduced
or no queue wait times so you can
iterate and innovate more quickly than
ever before
the cloud HPC toolkit is an open source
product developed by Google that makes
it easy to configure and deploy HPC
blueprints that Define a complete Cloud
HPC environment in this tutorial I will
show you how to deploy the healthcare
and life science blueprint
which includes an auto scaling HPC
cluster for running molecular
simulations and a visualization
environment that enables you to interact
with and visualize the results of your
experiments
to learn more about the HPC toolkit I
recommend you watch the previous videos
in this series Linked In the description
below
let's start by taking a look at the
architecture of the cluster
we will be deploying the components
needed for high performance compute jobs
including GPU enabled compute nodes for
Accelerated Computing a file store
instance for NFS shared storage
and cloud storage buckets that are
automatically mounted to work with input
and output data easily
in addition a dedicated Builder VM will
compile and install molecular Dynamics
software on the shared file Store and
install vmd visualization software on
the remote desktop this architecture
uses a slurm HPC cluster for running
jobs the HPC toolkit includes other
options too like batch a fully managed
batch service for running jobs on
Google's infrastructure
let's dive into the demo to see this in
action
I'll be working in the cloud shell where
I have already installed the HPC toolkit
which includes the hcls blueprint and
the ghpc command line tool
this is the hcls blueprint a text file
describing our HPC environment
you will notice similar high-level
Concepts in the blueprint as shown in
the architecture slide like storage
software
remote desktop
and the slurm cluster
now we can create a deployment using the
toolkit's ghpc command line tool
running ghpc create will print any
additional commands that you need to run
to deploy this blueprint
this is a multi-stage deployment that
requires time to build the software
the tutorial Linked In the description
has a complete set of instructions
once the deployment is complete you can
navigate to the cloud console web
interface for compute engine to see that
you've deployed a remote desktop VM a
slurm controller a login node and the
dedicated Builder VM
to connect to the remote desktop using
Chrome remote desktop configure the
connection using the steps described in
the tutorial which I've already done
to show how researchers can use this
environment will simulate the Dynamics
of lysozyme using gromax a molecular
Dynamics package
let's take a look at the protein using
vmd
as part of the deployment the pdb file
for lysozyme has been downloaded to the
input directory which is a Google Cloud
Storage bucket mounted to the remote
desktop and the cluster lysozyme is an
anti-microbial enzyme that attacks the
protective cell walls of bacteria
before running a gromac simulation
several steps need to be performed first
that have been collected into a single
submission script in my home directory
let's take a look at the submission
script now
these steps include
preparing the input
generating a topology
solvating the system
minimizing the potential energy and
equilibrating the system before running
the production run
you can find the submission script in
the repository Linked In the description
now let's SSH into the login node
copy the pdb file in place
and submit the job to the cluster
once the job is submitted the cluster
Auto scales a GPU compute node to run
the simulation
once the simulation finishes we can
return to the remote desktop to view the
simulation results
like the input directory the output
directory is a Google Cloud Storage
bucket mounted to the cluster and the
remote desktop
this means the results are accessible
from the remote desktop without ever
needing to export any data from the
cloud
let's take a look at the simulation
results in vmd
here you can see the Dynamics of
lysozyme generated in our experiment
since the results are stored in the
cloud they are immediately available for
use cases like Ai and ml in vertex AI
data analytics in bigquery and
interactive analysis and vertex
workbench
in this tutorial I demonstrated how to
use the HPC toolkit to deploy the hls
blueprint and utilize a remote desktop
to view the molecular Dynamic simulation
results
if you want to run it yourself follow
the steps in the tutorial Linked In the
description below
[Music]